حقيقه يعني جهود حديثه هنا بالنسبه
للسلطات المحليه سواء على صعيد فرق
الانقاذ او على صعيد
البلديات في محاوله احتواء هذه الازمه
والتخفيف من وسطتها على السكان اليوم
انتهى انتهت اعمال البحث في الموقعين
اخرين في مدينه غازي عنتاب وقد يعني
شاهدنا هذا الامر قبل قليل
وانتقلت فريق الانقاذ من هذين الموقعين
الى مواقع اخرى لمسانده الفرق الاخرى هذا
احد المواقع الذي تستمر به عمليه البحث
عن ناجين يامن هؤلاء الاشخاص من فرق
الانقاذ ان يجدوا ناجين تحت الانقاذ خصوصا
بعد الاشخاص الذين خرجوا في غازي عنتاب
يوم امس وفي الولايات الاخرى غازي عنتاب
امس في مدينه الاصلاحيه خرج رجل وابنته من
تحت الانقال وقد رصدنا هذا الامر وكنا
متواجدين في ذلك الموقع وكانوا قد قضوا
نحو 131 ساعه بالنسبه لم
التابعات لولايه غازي عنتاب اداريا هنالك
اكثر من 19 قيمه بعد ان كان هنالك 15 الف
خيمه الان 19 الف قيمه في ولايه غاز عنتاب
العدد يمكن ان يرتفع الى 25 الف قيمه وفق
ما قال وزير الاسكان عندما زار مدينه
الاصلاحيه برفقه فاطمه شاهين قبل يومين
وايضا هناك اكثر من الف بيت متنقل تم
تجهيزها لاستضافه الاشخاص المتضررين
والمنكوبين هم لهم الاولويه بالنسبه
للحكومه التركيه ومن ثم يتم التعامل
والتعاطي مع الاشخاص الذين هربوا بسبب هذا
الزلزال الذين يتخوفون من ان تسقط مبانيهم
من هذا الزلزال خصوصا ان عدد كبير من
المباني قد تصدعت كما يعني ذكرنا في وقت
سابق وهناك تشققات وهناك تخوف وذعر بين
الاهالي بالنسبه لهذا الامر ايضا الجيش
التركي شاهدناه في مدينه الاصلاحيه وفي
نورداغ يشارك في عمليات الانقاذ وايضا
يؤمن المدينتين لان المده تلك المدينتين
في ماده مارك كبير جدا يعني لا يكاد يكون
منزل الا الا مدمر اما جزء منه او او بشكل
كامل او نصف هذا البيت لذلك هم يقومون
بعمليات الحمايه خصوصا في قضيه السرقه
التي تحدث عنها الرئيس التركي اردوغان
والاشخاص الذين حاولوا ان يستغلوا هذه
الظروف وظروف الفوضى التي شهدتها هذه
المدن بسبب الزلزال وبداوا بعمليات السرقه
لذلك تدخل الجيش التركي وانتشر في تلك
المناطق وبدا بمساعده في عمليات الانقاذ
وايضا بدا بتامين الحمايه للمنشات
في حينما المدنيين انتقلوا من تلك المدن
الى الخيام ومنهم من غادر الى ولايات اخرى
هربا من هذا الزلزال يعني منتصر